[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMBIT SAMAL: Good afternoon,
and hopefully you're
having a great
time here in Next.
What we're going to
do today is we're
going to talk about the G
Suite developer platform.
It is also known as the
Knowledge Intelligence
Platform.
You might have seen
that in the title.
I just did not change the
name because we use it
interchangeably here.
So what are we going to do
today is we're going to--
I'll give you a sense of what
knowledge intelligence is
about, and how it is related
to the developer platform
that we are going to talk
about, how you can leverage
some of the concepts, and
some of the capabilities
that we will enable
in our platform,
and build these amazing apps.
So my name is Sambit.
I'm the product manager here.
I'm the lead product
manager for the area.
And let's get started.
So you might be wondering, yet
another developer platform?
We know so many of them.
Now another one there?
I think it will be helpful to
clarify, at least in Google
context, what are we
trying to do here,
how is it different
from what we are trying
to achieve in terms of GCP.
So as part of a G
Suite developer,
our focus is on this aspect
called low-code and no-code.
What I mean by that
is, imagine a world
where most of your
application need and most
is kind of a
nebulous word, let's
say 80% of your
application need.
You can do it.
You can visually compose
and not have to code.
So that means not only you guys,
but anybody in your company
can develop an app.
So that would be the
concept of no-code.
And a low-code is where you,
with a little bit of sort
of no-coding, until we reach
the complete no-code state--
I don't know when
that will happen--
but you can build the
app that you need.
And the third categories of
code where the GCP belongs
is where you can put
and self-build anything
that is possible.
That is a full
stack development.
You can build anything, right?
And the idea here
is, we will create
such a compelling
experience that even
the full stack developer
will, in most cases,
use the no-code and
low-code platform.
So that's our modest goal,
not like a GCP kind of a goal,
where you can build anything.
Now, this is our mission.
Our mission is to enable
you to build application
quickly and easily.
And I'll double
down on that, what
I mean by the quick and easy.
What I mean by quick and
easy is two concepts,
which is called the apps
gap and the skill gap.
So all of you might have
seen this situation, where
a person comes to you from
one of your sort of line
of business, and
say, I need this app.
I'm using, let's say, one of
the ERP app or the CRM app,
but I need this one little thing
or this one little workflow.
And your answer
typically will be,
yeah, I know, I have this
in 100 projects on my plate.
So this goes to the bottom.
Or the guy might say, hey,
this is the number one
priority for our CXO, so you
need to get going on this fast.
So then you have to drop
something from your plate
to take this on, right?
Why does that happens?
That happens
because you cannot--
even with all the solutions that
are available in the market,
you cannot meet all the needs
of all the people that you need
to serve in your organization,
all the time, right?
So there is a gap
in the app space.
And you only have the
skill to build that,
and when someone new comes in,
a line of business partner,
you don't have the
skill to build that.
So that is a skill gap.
So there's two solution to that.
So one is make all your
line-of-business partners
to acquire the skills
that you have so
that everybody can develop, or
probably a better solution is,
make the platform such
that anybody can develop.
Make the non-developers,
or the people
who are in the line of
business, developers.
Give them the tools so
that they can develop.
If you do that, then they
can build on their own,
so you're bridging
the skill gap,
and they can build
the app that they
want instead of coming to you.
So that is the app gap,
and the skills gap concept.
If you're successful
in both, then you
will allow application to
be built quickly and easily.
Let me double down on that, and
break this mission into-- sort
of into three things which
are a little more concrete.
When you use G Suite,
you know, you have--
like from a database, you want
to bring it out to Sheets.
You need to have approval
workflow with the identity
that you have many of
these applications.
So all this may not
be easily provided
in the off-the-shelf
solution that we provide.
So that means you have
to extend G Suite to meet
these functionality needs.
And as I talked about, we
want to enable that use case
for both developers
and non-developers,
so that is our first goal, to
make it useful to everyone.
And the second thing is we want
to offer this as a platform.
Today, many of the tools
that you might be using,
things like App Maker, or
Apps Script, and other tools,
they are offered sort
of as disparate products
on their own.
They stand on their own.
But what we want to do is
bring to you a platform,
which provides the end-to-end
experience for a developer,
so that whatever you
need as a developer--
and here, you know, I'm talking
about non-developers also--
it is provided that.
So that is the first thing.
The second thing is
that I want to hit on
is the concept of assistive
experience and enterprise
knowledge.
So let me explain
what I mean by that.
So let's talk about
enterprise knowledge first.
So let's say, you know,
you join a company new.
And you are tasked with
doing contract negotiations.
You don't know how
contract negotiations
happen in your company.
So what do you do?
The first thing you do is
talk to your supervisor,
or talk to your colleagues,
or talk to your friends
in the company, to figure
out who is the person who
has done this before, and how
can I approach that person,
or talk to that person?
So then that person maybe
direct you to some other person,
and then you eventually
reach that person.
So that means this
knowledge that is there
in the enterprise,
which is, who is
the expert here in
this particular area,
is not institutionalized.
It is there in
someone's head, right?
The same thing applies
to things like document.
Which are the best
documents that describe
contract negotiation process?
You don't know that.
You are new to the company.
And there is no way
you can get that.
And that knowledge is, again,
with someone who knows what
is the document that
you need to refer to.
These are sort of the
enterprise knowledge,
we are talking about.
And you can extend
this to, let's say,
who are our best customers?
Who are our most loyal customers
that we want to take care of?
Who are best customer
service representatives?
These are knowledge that
is there in the enterprise.
And it is not in an
accessible format
or not in
institutionalized format.
So that's what the enterprise
knowledge refers to.
It is that the knowledge that
is there in the enterprise,
is it there in an
accessible format or not,
or is it in someone's head?
The second concept
here is what we are
calling assistive experience.
Assistive means
something which allows
you to do your main task.
It helps you to
do your main task.
It doesn't take over the
task, but in some way
it takes away the
mundane from the task,
and help you focus
on the main task.
So let me give you a
real world example.
So any of us who is driving
a little bit of a newer car
will know that you have lot
of what is called drive assist
features, so keep
you in the lane,
allow you to look
at the blind spot,
or warn you to look at the
blind spot, adaptive cruise.
The main task, which is
driving, is not going away,
but some of these
side tasks the vehicle
allows you to take care so that
you can just focus on driving.
Now remember this is completely
different from autonomous
driving, which is the
main task, which is
the driving getting replaced.
So the assistive experience is
taking away some of the task
and helps you drive.
So let's bring it back
to sort of our world,
and I'll give you three
different examples
of like in IT how it is useful.
Think about an end
user experience.
So the end user experience--
and you might probably have seen
this in the keynote--
is all of us, we
schedule meetings.
So when you schedule
meetings, we
can say that, OK, I want
to meet person x and y.
Won't it be nice if I exchange
sort of mails with someone,
and from the mail I can just
hit something, hit a button,
and it goes, based on the
context, and schedules
a meeting?
And it not only
schedules a meeting,
it finds out the
meeting room for you.
So this is truly possible.
What you want next is or
to make it more magical is,
based on the context,
based on the understanding
of the context, if you
are able to figure out
what are the document that will
be relevant to the context,
and you provide the links
in that meeting invite.
What will even be more magical--
because a lot of us have
to write an agenda
for the meeting,
it's based on what I will
discuss and it is happening--
it provides a draft agenda
in the invite itself.
So that is an example
of assistive experience,
because you still
have do the meeting,
but this part of
scheduling the meeting
and drafting an
agenda and things
like that, you don't
have to do anymore,
so that is taken care
of by the system.
So that is an
assistive experience
in an end user sense.
Now think of an admin.
If you're an
enterprise admin, you
are thinking of buying
different applications
from the marketplace.
Let's say you go to the
G Suite marketplace,
and you are getting,
or you are trying
to decide what are
the applications that
would be helpful to me.
So in that context,
let's say, today you
go to the G suite marketplace.
It just shows you
a lot of apps based
on popularity or some criteria.
It is not contextualized
to your own situation.
So in a world of tomorrow,
what will happen is,
based on whatever is
ongoing in your enterprise,
the marketplace, the
app in the marketplace,
the automation in
the marketplace,
or the items in the marketplace,
is curated to your need.
The system understand
what you need right now
and shows you the
applications or the items
that you need right now.
And that means the admin can
choose the application that he
needs much more easier way.
Now, let's say it gives you
three different choices.
What will happen is the admin
will go look at the reviews
or figure out how good
the application is
and do some evaluation and
bring it to the enterprise.
Won't it be nice if the
reviews are summarized for you,
and the pros and cons
are spelled out for you,
and based on your need you
can dial up and dial down,
and based on that you decide
which applications to buy?
That is another example of admin
using assistive experience.
And the same thing can we
think about a developer, where
based on what kind of
code you are writing,
if you are writing a code on,
let's say, accessing mail API,
we know the pattern
is, after the mail API,
you invoke a Calendar API,
we can suggest you the code
blocks, so that you
can build that app.
So that is an assistive
experience for developers.
So we want to enable those
sort of experience which
takes care of assistive, as
well as enterprise knowledge.
The third thing, like I
talked about, our goal here
is to make this kind
of technologies,
build this capabilities
into the platform,
so that it is
accessible to everyone.
All kinds of developers, and
all kinds of non-developers,
everybody in the
enterprise should
be able to access these
sort of applications.
So those are our
three key goals.
Now imagine if we
are successful.
So this goes to the
online developer,
developer, developer.
You know where this came
from, and we want that.
But developers
are a finicky lot.
They don't adapt a platform
unless and until it
is useful for them.
We think by making it
really quick and really easy
so that you can visually
compose application
all with a little bit of
code and bringing together
this assistive experience
with the ability
to access enterprise
knowledge, we'll
be able to create enough
differences that developers
will be willing to
adapt this platform.
Now if they adapt this
platform, what do we get?
We get lots and lots
of intelligent apps.
These are intelligent,
because you
are building
assistive experience
using enterprise knowledge.
And what you can do is you
can combine first party, which
is Google Cloud and G Suite
apps, with third party, which
is a different service provider,
and you are in the middle.
You can orchestrate within
all three different ecosystem
to build the right kind
of apps that you need.
And that itself leads
to a virtuous ecosystem
which creates a lot of--
lots and lots of apps.
Now the key message of
this particular platform
is knowledge intelligence.
Now let's discuss how
knowledge intelligence is
different from
enterprise knowledge.
Now remember, in an
enterprise knowledge,
you have to pre-think
what exactly you want.
If you want-- who are
your loyal customers
or who is the best customer
service representative,
you have to think through and
build this into the system
and make it accessible
to the system,
accessible to the application
using some particular system
or some particular algorithm.
So that is an explicit
declarative way
of getting this information.
Now, like business
intelligence, if we
provide you the capability
by which you can
leverage your own data, right?
You know, you control your data.
And using the technology
that we provide,
you don't have to
pre-think that beforehand,
but we will allow
you to take advantage
of the information that is
there in your enterprise
and extract out
those information
and make it accessible
to your application.
So that is what knowledge
intelligence means.
It is an informed
knowledge versus
an explicit and declarative
knowledge, right?
So imagine, if you are
able to do that, then you
know what is possible.
Is Google-- when I said,
Google could understand that,
and, of course, you know, we
will build that capability,
but then it's up
to you whether you
want to take advantage
of this capability to get
more out of your business.
So if you get able
to do that, if you're
able to leverage this
knowledge intelligence,
along with the
developer platform
which allows you to take
advantage of all the things
that are there, then
imagine what you can build.
So you can build the next
generation of app, the apps
that we talked about, where you
can potentially have a customer
support call from your
most loyal customer routed
through the best
representative that
can serve that particular
customer at that instant,
those kind of game changing
apps that you can build,
which can really
transform your business.
So to summarize, what
are we going to do?
So we are going to help you
build these new apps, which
can rethink your business.
And to do that,
what we will do is
we'll help you
gather information
about your processes,
people, systems,
and we will derive the
insights and provide
the tools that allow you
to tap into the systems.
And once you tap
into the system,
you can then build sort of the
next generation of productivity
app using some [INAUDIBLE]
and other techniques
to predict and automate
a lot of these tasks.
So that is what you can do with
this next generation of apps
that you are going to build.
But the question is,
this is a grand vision.
Are we-- how we think
we are able to do that?
You know, this is like
nice smoke and mirrors.
What makes us think
that we will be
able to build that capability?
I think there are two
fundamental arguments.
There's the Google
way of looking at it,
and that's what makes
us sort of confident
that we'll be able
to hit those goals.
So number one, we are primarily
a cloud native platform, so
that means, anything that
you use-- primal everything,
the whole corpus
of information--
resides in the cloud.
There is no, sort
of, for most part,
on prem and off prm
kind of a thing.
What does that allow?
That allows two things.
One is, because we are at
one place on the cloud,
so that means the
knowledge itself is not
split between two
different places,
so that means we have the
full picture of the knowledge.
The second thing is, the
most real-time information
is available in the cloud.
So, the context, for example,
whether you are at work,
whether you are at home,
whether you are holding
a mobile device, or whether
you are on a desktop,
that information is available.
And that is relevant,
because the way
you deliver the application
will be dependent on that.
So the cloud native way
allows you to, first of all,
get the complete
set of information,
and allow the most
real-time decision possible.
So that is the first advantage.
And the second advantage we have
is in AI and machine learning.
We think that we have
earned the right, based
on some of the things
that we have done.
We are phenomenally better
than our competition
in understanding the
space and delivering
sort of on applications
that leverage
this sort of technologies.
And using those tools, I think
we can realize the vision
that we just talked about.
I talked about
developer platform.
So what does the development
platform is made up of?
So like any other
developer platform,
we'll provide the best
available developer platform.
We will provide all
these different things
that you expect out of
a developer platform.
We'll provide tools.
We'll provide documentation.
We'll provide Canonical Apps.
We'll provide APIs.
We'll help build the community.
And competence is one of the
different pieces I'm going
to talk in the following slide.
But essentially, you can
take the platform and use
that to orchestrate between
the first party, which
is the Google services and
applications with third party
using the platform.
And we'll offer this in
an integrated fashion.
So it will be a unified
experience in the sense
that it'll look
like it is coming
from the same company
or the same provider
instead of looking
very disparate.
And this will be consisting of
this particular aspect, which
is the development environment.
We'll provide you the
coordinating tool,
and the components, and tools.
We'll provide the runtime.
We'll provide different
infrastructure tools,
and these will be infrastructure
in terms of administering
your app, monitoring your app.
And we'll provide a
marketplace in which
you can publish these apps.
And we'll help
you take advantage
of, as I said, in a G Suite
ecosystem, the GCP ecosystem,
and the third party services.
All these three will be
critical for your success.
So now let's talk about
something concrete.
What are the pieces or
what are the components
of this platform?
So like I said, all
these tools will
be integrated into one
platform-- the developer
platform.
So the first column
that we talked about
is the different development
tools and the runtime.
So we have an App Maker, Apps
Script, and add-ons there.
Our goal is to make App Maker
sort of the no-code solution
to build your app.
So it may not be there.
It may fall short right now
in realizing the vision,
but the goal there is we should
provide a visually composable
way to build an app, and
that's why App Maker is there,
and that is the no-code segment.
And Apps Script
will be what we call
the low-code segment,
where with some code
you'll be able to build that.
And add-ons is about bringing
together the host application
context into your application
that you are building.
So that is the first thing
that we are going to offer.
The second thing is
once you build the app,
you need a way to publish it so
that other people can use that.
It could be in your
domain, or it could
be outside of your domain.
And we will make sure that the
published part of it from each
of this development environment,
you can easily publish that,
and the admin can easily bring
into their enterprise using
the marketplace.
The third column there is
data connectors, automation,
and APIs.
Now we acknowledge that today we
don't have a good story there.
That is a gap that
we acknowledge,
and we are working to fix that.
Data connectors will be sort
of a connection mechanism
to your on prem
and other clouds.
And we understand that, today,
there is no way from G Suite
to do that.
We are thinking about
it and working on it,
and you should hear
more in probably--
soon, next few months, you
should be hearing something
about that.
So this will allow
you to access--
because you know, right now,
we know all of us cannot move
to cloud straightaway, so we'll
have some on prm some off prm
So it is important that we
connect the on prm off prm
experience, and the data
connectors will be the way
to do that.
The second thing is on
automation and workflow.
In the enterprise
workload, you may
have lot of interprocess flows
which needs to be automated,
and both from a
line-of-business standpoint,
and from individual standpoint,
individual productivity
standpoint.
And today, we don't have
a clear solution there.
Again, this is one of the
space that we are working on,
and this will allow you to build
automations in a no-code way,
and that's what we are
looking forward to.
And we hope we will
have something for you
in the next few months.
And the third thing is APIs.
Traditionally, our API surface
has not been very smooth,
and if you have
developed using our API,
you will see it has been a
little bit rough on the edges.
We are looking at that.
We will make sure that we take
a API first approach where
all our products
have APIs, and they
are accessible in the same way.
And so stay tuned, and
we will have more things
to talk about in the next
few quarters or few months.
And the last part of it
is administrative tools.
We acknowledge that we are not--
we don't have a great story.
We have been delivering
features on that,
but it is not an integrated
suite of admin tools
that we have
delivered, but again
that is something which
we understand and we
will be delivering that.
So all those four pieces will
form the backbone of developer
platforms, and that is what we
want to deliver going forward.
So, on that journey,
you know, this
is the first thing we would
like to announce today, right.
In all our projects,
all our tools, now we
will have one single place
where you can access.
So, whether it is API,
documentations, community,
or anything like
that, all the tools.
We are calling it the
G Suite Developer Hub,
and now instead of
going to different URLs,
you just go to this place,
and you'll get everything
that you need from this place.
And we are in the process
of rolling this out.
We will provide
you the exact URL.
This will get plugged in to
the G Suite developer site,
or the Google developer site.
And this is all you need
to know going forward.
All our new product,
new features,
new documentation, everything
will come into this place.
OK?
The second part of our
journey is App Maker.
So thank you for people
who have been using
App Maker for a long time.
It took a long time to GA.
But I think you know we have
App Maker in a good place right
now.
We launched on 14 June, so
it's been about a month,
but the response
from the enterprises
has been tremendous.
So these are the number
of customers to domains
here matched to customers.
And we have more than 3,000
apps that have been developed.
We have more than
50,000 users using it
in a 28-day active
occurrence right now.
So that is why we have the
second announcement here,
which is--
I mean, it is already launched.
I just wanted to hit on
the some of the numbers.
So that is something that
you need to think about.
So that's all I have.
If you have any
questions, there is a mic,
and I'll be happy to
take any questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]